[Music]
Um, welcome everybody. This is a little
bit last minute, so bear with me. If you
don't know me, uh, I started Century a
long time ago. David Kramer. I'm sort of
an engineer, sort of an executive, sort
of a founder. Uh, I would like to think
I have rational opinions. So that's what
this is
going to
complicated. It's just big scary words.
So if you do, great. If you don't, maybe
you walk away, you're like, "Yeah, I
thought that's what it was. We've done
it."
Mostly, uh, I was asked a couple days
ago while I snuck my way into this
conference if I could fill a slot. And
so filling this slot was like, "Oh, come
give some hot takes. Maybe spice it up a
little bit." So that's what we're going
to do. It's not going to be too much of
a rant. If you know me, I like to rant,
but you know, we'll dial back for this
one a little bit. So what is an MCP? You
know, I I got to say this is like one of
the wildest phenomenons. I It's like the
new crypto wave or something.
Everybody's like, "Yeah, MCP. We don't
know what it is, but we're here for it."
And you find a lot of these sort of like
opinions around, you know, how it should
be, how it shouldn't be. And you know
what I often find is people who have
these opinions have not built anything
or at least not built the thing they're
talking about. I built Century's MCP
server mostly as a fun project. Um so
take this for what it is. Um it's also
Century's MCP server. These are biased
opinions towards what Sentry is. If
you're not familiar with Sentry, you
probably should be, but we do
application monitoring. We do a bunch of
stuff. Um if you have bugs on the
internet, they probably go to us. Uh and
so it's in context of a B2B SAS
business. A lot of you probably work at
enterprise companies if you will. So
think about it that way. But the way we
think about MCP is it is a pluggable
architecture for agents. Full stop.
That's it. It's pretty simple to reason
about.
And again,
all of this is contextualized in an
enterprise cloud service kind of way.
There's a lot of other variations of how
you might adapt MCP. There's tool chains
that make sense locally. We're talking
about we run cloud services. That's most
of the industry. We're B2B. we're
enterprise. I think a lot of this
actually still applies. Um, but take
that with a grain of salt. So, how we
think about MCP with Sentry particularly
because this again relevant here. We fix
bugs. There are things like cursor where
you also fix bugs. What if we could all
fix bugs together? And so everything's
contextualized in that. And I think
there's this whole thing of like how do
we be relevant? That's like the the name
of the game for every single company in
the world right now. Um, is like oh how
how do we become an AI company?
We too are now an AI company. Um, but
Sentry has a lot of bugs. I fix those in
my editor. Wouldn't it be cool if the
bugs could be inside my editor
sometimes? That's a great example of
where maybe an MCP is useful, but at the
very least we're going to pretend it's
useful. So, that's the context here. Um,
but it all comes back to like probably
the reason everybody's here is like, how
do I become relevant? I've got an AI
mandate. I've got infinite money to
spend all of a sudden for some reason
that didn't exist yesterday. How do we
get involved? Okay, so everybody
probably same stage. I know how this
works. So,
all right. Um, we built this a few
months ago. We are not first to market
with MCP.
And the reason why is because the
there's two interfaces for MCPS. I'm
going to focus on a remote interface,
but there's also the standard IO. You
probably learned about that or know
something about that. I don't think
standard IO is super useful for
businesses like ours. I'll talk about
that, but but sort of the analogy of why
MCP is useful. This is VS Code Insiders,
which you just uh heard from Harold, but
like they do a pretty good job. They're
the only ones with OAS support that's
like useful today. Cursor promised me
end of week. I don't know, hold them to
that. Um, but it works pretty well. You
plug in Century's MCP, you can look up
data from Sentry and a bunch of curated
workflows. You can maybe fix some bugs,
maybe easier than it was before, or at
least more fun than it was before. Um,
and for the sake of this, I I needed a
screen grab. So, last night I'm like
literally last night I'm working on
these slides and I go into VS Code. And
I'm like, I'm just going to plug it in.
I don't have time to fuss around if the
thing's going to break. And so I use the
VS Code and I'm like, okay, I'll just do
a thing where it's like, fix all my bugs
for me. And then immediately it does
like 20 API queries this entry. Probably
cost me like five bucks to run this
thing. Um,
but it did start fixing some bugs. Uh, I
don't know if the fixes were good, mind
you. They're they're probably garbage.
Um, but it does the thing, right? It's
like it brought context into the editor,
which is what we want. And that context
was provided by somebody else. Sentry in
this case. So that is like one of the
interesting things. It's one of the
interesting things we think about and
why MCP is like like valuable to sort of
a traditional I don't know we're kind of
an enterprise company but like like
every company in the world and that's
part of why we're all hopping on it.
It's pretty accessible and that's what
I'm going to talk about. It is actually
super accessible. So
this is you. This was me. Um and this is
why I have opinions about it now. It's
like oh it's just an API plugs in. We've
got an API. we've got some OOTH going
on. You know, we had our own OOTH
provider. You know, a lot of you might
use something like a work OS or, I don't
know, pick one of these authentication
services that just gives you it out of
the box. If you have that, you're pretty
much ready to go, which is pretty cool.
It's actually like a pretty low
boilerplate uh implementation. Um, but
then you quickly learn that it's
actually not that easy. And so, first
you kind of go into this OOTH like dance
and you're like, "Oh, okay." Like, yeah,
we're going to do this, but it needs
oath 2.1 and nobody in the world
supports this thing. like it's like I
don't know how old it is, but I had
never heard of it before MCP. Um, and so
there's a little bit of complexity
there, but you're like, "Okay, it's
almost there. It's OOTH. We've got that.
We can plug it into our API." You kind
of get it working. In our case, we use
Cloudflare Shim, which basically lets us
proxy our OOTH 2 API on top of
Cloudflare workers, which has a 2.1
client registration thing. I don't know
if anybody's talked about that. TLDDR,
it's complicated. Um, but it's not that
complicated. This was built in a couple
days, mind you, and I'm also an
executive at the company. So, it's like,
yeah, if I can do it, everybody can do
it. Um, but you go through the OOTH flow
and then you're like, cool, but the the
robots don't know actually how to reason
about giant JSON payloads that were not
built for them. And this is actually
where I think a lot of people break
down. There was like a big conversation.
This is sort of one of my first
opinions, if you will, what I might call
common sense, is that MCP is not a thing
that just sits on top of Open API. Like
you cannot just be like I got an API.
I'm going to expose all those end points
as tools. You're going to get the worst
results you can possibly imagine. You're
be like oh this doesn't make any sense.
You have to massage everything. You have
to design around the system. But like
generally speaking, and I'll talk a
little bit about this, like you need to
really think about how would you use an
agent today? How do the models react to
what you do when you provide them
context, which is what this really is
for, and design a system around that. So
might leverage your API. It is not your
API. And then you get past that and you
wire it up to things like cursor and VS
code and you're like why is this
breaking all the time? You can't you
can't solve for that one. It's just you
got to wait for everybody to catch up.
They're almost there. Uh you know
handful of clients support native
authentication now. They're kind of
stable. Um to the code's credit, it
hasn't broken much recently. Cursor's
broken quite a lot on me, but they're
both great. Don't get me wrong. Cloud
has support. Cloud Code has sort of
support, but not really. Um, so I guess
it might work, it might not. I think
particularly in the developer ecosystem,
we're much more ahead of the curve. And
so if you're trying to adapt your
services to third party agents that are
in our ecosystem like these editors,
you've probably got a good shot of it
working tomorrow,
if I don't know, it's Salesforce or
something. I have no idea. So So you're
you're kind of beholden to like the
clients and the implementation because
again, it's a plug-in architecture for
agents. Um there's a lot of other use
cases that are not just third parties,
but that's kind of the focus. And so I'm
going to try to be constructive from
here. Let's see, we got nine minutes. Um
just a few learnings and I'm happy to
talk more about this later. I'll be
around. Um
you'll probably somebody in this room is
going to disagree with this, but you
should only care about OOTH if you're a
B2B SAS company like me. Um
and particularly you care about OOTH
with remote environments for the most
part. If you're like, "How do I
integrate my services into various
agents?
I want bugs to exist in cursor." I want
to run a cloud service. And I want to
run a cloud service for the exact same
reason I've always wanted to run a cloud
service because I can iterate on it. I
can ship fast. I can dial in security.
All the advantages it turns out are
exactly the same because technology has
not changed. And so if I were you and
you're not building something hyper
specific that is like a local
devicecentric thing just focus on the
remote MCP server focus on the O
specification and just like don't worry
about it. The the problems will solve
themselves. Security will solve itself
because there's a whole world of
security problems and the standard IO
interface is filled with most of them.
Um I'm not going to talk about that. I'm
sure there's some other talks here about
prompt injection but it is like very
very very scary. Do not allow random MCP
tools in your organization. Um, trust
people that have earned trust. Don't
download random packages off the
internet. Uh, it will be a very bad time
for your organization. Um, I did mention
this cloud desktop has I think full OS
support right now in production in G. VS
Code Insiders has it. Um, these are
great because you just drop in the MCP
URL and it handles everything from
there. Cursor like I said I think this
week. Um, I don't know about anybody
else. I don't pay attention much beyond
anybody else and I think cloud code has
not at least I've not seen anything. Um,
and then there's a bunch like a long
tail, right? So, works pretty well.
There is this MCP remote package which
is how we shipped all this stuff. It
works okay. I applaud early adopters for
getting this out. It's not a great
experience and you'll find a lot of this
is not a great user experience. It's
rough. It's beta. That's fine. Um, this
is the biggest thing going back to the
open API thing. You actually have to
spend the calories. You can't just be
like, "Haha, we proxied Open API and
exposed it as tools. It's going to do
nothing." And so, what the right answer
here is, who knows? um our version of
this and I'll talk a little bit about
why is like we return markdown. We've
we've taken some API endpoints and we've
directly translated some of the response
to markdown but it's intentional. It's
like I want to get a bug out of Sentry.
I'm just going to give you the bare
essentials. I'm going to give it in a
structured way that a human can reason
about because generally speaking, if a
human can reason about it, the language
model can reason about it because it's
effectively pattern matching on
language. um it can kind of figure out
JSON here and there, but if if you
actually push it, you're going to find
it breaks all the time. So, just use
something like Markdown. Um it's not
scientific. I think there's a lack of
science in a lot of this. It's hard.
Just go with whatever works. But you you
have to really think about you don't
control the the consumer. You don't
control the model. And so, you're kind
of like this least common denominator
thing. And so, think about that. But you
need to design the system and you need
to treat it as like you are providing
context to an agent that you don't know
what the agent is doing, right? And so,
that's the name of the game is context.
that same thing. Uh sorry, here's an
example of that. I forgot what my slides
were. Uh we just like give kind of a
reasonable description of tools as the
first version of context. Um which
sometimes you hit token limits with all
this. So there's some other challenges.
We give a reasonable description of a
tool with the hopes that clients figure
out how to make use of this context. So
it can call the right tool. It can call
it when it needs to. It can choose one
tool over the other tool, which is a
really unfortunately hard problem for it
to figure out. Um mostly
straightforward.
errors. Same thing. You got to design
the errors. They are still context
because just like a human can't figure
out how to call your API, the machine
also can't figure out how to call your
API. In my example, I'm like fix all my
bugs for me. And it it queries like
every organization in century that I
have access to. It queries all it's like
like 20 API calls when it should have
been one even with all this context. So
we are a long ways from this being
great. But it's like a glimmer, right?
So you know in this case it's like oh
you didn't pass the the thing or rather
you pass an invalid value for the thing.
give it a real human response. This is
now more important than ever because
again it's not just a sort of machine
reasoning about it where you can
hardcode all this stuff. It's abstract.
You don't know who's reasoning about it.
The biggest thing and this is sort of
leading to like the my overarching view
of the world is like you don't you have
no control which already is a problem.
You are also passing the cost on in a
lot of these cases. So you actually kind
of need to be mindful. So another reason
to not just be like here's my API. I'm
just going to return everything to you
because all of a sudden, you know, that
that call, if you will, that tool call
that could have been a dollar might be
$10 now because of the amount of tokens
you needed. And more importantly, it
might just not work. Like early on in
and I don't know if VS Code and or
OpenAI, I don't know who's to blame, fix
this, but like there was and may still
be a limit to the amount of tokens or
description lengths of tools. Makes
sense, right? You want to constrain the
cost of every API call, but all of a
sudden now you have problems again. So,
you got to be really thoughtful about
this. This is going to be evolved. And I
think the big thing is like if you build
one of these, it's not set and forget.
Like we're still updating this thing
every week, tweaking it here and there,
trying to look at like what's happening
and evolving it, right? But the biggest
thing, and this is sort of my my
takeaway, my my very very strong belief
is like you just need to really focus on
building agents. MCP is a plug-in
architecture. There's a lot of value
behind it, but the like the inherent
value of a lot of what LLM are bringing
is this sort of agent architecture,
which by the way is just a service
architecture with a fancy new word on
it. Common sense kind of stuff, right?
Um, and so we've done this in Century.
It does not work well with MCP yet for
for what it's worth. There is no
streaming responses for tools yet. And
that's a big problem when you think
about sort of this agent to agent. And I
don't mean this in like the Google way.
I mean in like the generalized point of
view of agent to agent. Um, but it gives
you control and it's it's the same as
all software. If you have control, you
can be responsible for the success, for
the failure. I can be responsible for
the prompt that dictates how the tool is
called. I can be responsible for the
result from the tool. I can make many
calls behind the scenes and wrap those
up. So I I just get a lot more control
if I pick up the cost of that agent. I
control the model even, right? And so I
think this is this is my big bet and I
think this is where B2B is going to
shine is when we start exposing agents
through the MCP architecture. Again,
treating MCP as a plug-in architecture.
We've done that with one of ours which
is this thing. We keep renaming it so
bear with me. It's like called Seir now,
but it's just like Century's got a lot
of data on what's broken in your
application. And we do this thing where
we do this really high quality root
cause analysis that's done via an agent.
Um we expose that root cause analysis
mostly to our UI to be fair. We also
expose it to the MCP but because it
doesn't do streaming we have to do like
some pulling check where it's like okay
start the job and then let's check in on
it a few times but then there because
the way agents work it just gives up at
some point. So it's a little complicated
but again beta testing the promise is
there. Um but when this works I I really
think this is going to be the value
unlock for a lot of us. Again, MCP does
a lot of things. It's an abstract
protocol. Um, but the agent analogy is
really good. Um, aside, all this is open
source. You can find Century's MCP
somewhere on the internet. You'll find
it on GitHub. I should say fair source.
There's some complexity there. This is
what the agent looks like in the UI.
Check it out if you haven't. We'll be
around. Give me feedback. Um, I think
the last thing I want to sort of part
with is just like this stuff is not that
hard. Um, it's quite broken all the
time, but it's not that hard. I again I
built it in two days. I got a lot of
jobs to do at the company. you can just
go build it and try it out and learn and
like all this stuff is pretty obvious. I
think the lesson we've learned at Sentry
uh or still are learning I should say.
Uh everybody is scared of all this stuff
because there's fancy new words for
everything. But the fancy new words are
just new words for the same thing. It's
just a new like code of paint, right?
You know MCP is just a plug-in
architecture. Agents are just services
like the the LLM calls or MCP calls
actually half of tools are just API
calls with a new response format, right?
So it's pretty accessible to do all
this. There's a lot of great like
technology that's been going on in here.
Um, like I said, we used a lot of
Cloudflare tech. We did not use
Cloudflare at all before this. And then
in a couple days, we're like, cool, we
can shim up a thing on on workers.
They've got an OOTH proxy for us.
Problem solved. And this is important
because we don't run websocket
infrastructure at Century. It's just not
a thing we had, right? And
unfortunately, the protocol requires
something like that, which makes it a
little bit annoying to adopt, but but
again, it's not that hard. It's pretty
easy to adopt. Uh, try it out. You'll
probably hit a lot of bugs, but just
stick with it. I I think this one will
stick around. Um, but I would really
dial in the thinking around agents and
how you're optimizing for context in the
workflows you understand for your data.
Uh, with that said, I will be around the
rest of the afternoon, probably at our
our booth in the expo hall if you want
to come chat. Uh, come say hi. I'm
always happy to like rant about other
things or give you my semi-informed
opinions. Um, I'm not an AI guy to be
clear, but um, cool. With that, you
know, thanks everybody for for showing
up to this talk in this wild conference,
which is interesting. and I'll call it
there.